un samedi matin dont le bourg du lorrain
au marché les clients regardent gouttes
et et finissent par acheter et les
fruits et légumes
[Musique]
je suis intéressant et monsieur julien
emma candia les bouquets garnis tout ce
que j'ai pu c'est un les prix
bref c'est la vie d'un marché comme tant
d'autres enfin celui-ci est quelque peu
différent ici les vendeurs sont tous
agriculteurs une fois par mois quelques
agriculteurs l'eau rhinois vont
directement aux consommateurs
l'acheteur est ainsi certain de la
traçabilité des produits
on sait ce roman est déjà mis tellement
près que c'est pas la peine de me
déplacer pour aller ailleurs
non c'est ça a lâché dans les grandes
surfaces
ça sonne de plus par tour et là on ne la
suivent ans le connaître les gens et de
voir ceux qui vous disent et de chez eux
il ne fait alors le public de bonne
qualité tous les agriculteurs laurie
noix sont conviés mais attention il est
indispensable que le sol de leur
exploitation soit aux normes allait
prouver aux consommateurs à toute la
population de la martinique il ya des
gens sérieux quand même qui travaillent
et qui peut pouvait et le sérieux
analyser les gentils on prend des
allures sol mais non tous les allergènes
ils sont live en analysant la ligue et
son corps est la pollution des sols
inquiète les martiniquais la mairie l'a
bien compris alors tout est mis en
oeuvre pour y remédier il ya un petit
entretien qui est fait l'exploitation
est visitée donc on va voir
l'exploitation et puis un certain nombre
de documents qui doit être qui doit être
fait
pour justement les analyses de sol pour
qu'effectivement lorsque les produits
sont proposés que soient proposés dans
de bonnes conditions
le marché des agriculteurs laurie noah
est organisé tous les deuxièmes samedis
du mois